oh you're a genius I know we've had a
lot of fun trying on Santa stuff and
pretending to be Santa's breaking in
Nets house but the whole point of being
Santa is to bring cheer to little kids
find somebody that has a want that you
can help fill whatever it is have you
two been good girls this year yes
what's your favorite kind of puppy my
new favorite puppies the other one for
my favorite children across the world we
have puppies that kiss the presents
before they go out just give them a
little extra dose of magic and I'm going
to tell you your presence will both have
puppy kisses listen to what they say
maybe ask him a question about it you
know just interact with them like you
would anybody what's your favorite
dinosaur you have little arms like a
trench to us your big arms for a
treasure so David watch out thank you
David
good eye touch Violetta I hear that you
really like science it's mostly
experiments with science and art what's
your favorite song the Titanic this is
close things that Leonardo DiCaprio is
very handsome but it's a movie based on
a horrible tragedy yeah I think you just
want to you want to talk to him like
like real people Sam you I hear that you
like beauty and fashion what's your
favorite thing I guess it would go to
makeup what makeup would you put on me
read Turkish lipstick yes girl how do
you get on to a nice list doing chores
doing your homework being obedient to
your parents
okay I clean up my room we help our mom
when she's sick and my sister so my
house with my prophet
yes she's also a very good girl you know
there's nothing more rewarding than
giving gift what do you want for
Christmas this year
American Girl doll maybe a little bit
maybe have Oh Santa knows American Girl
Santa made American Girl doll Wow yeah I
did though doing one computer hmm
present what about you Manuel black
Santa loves robots are you guys ready
for your presents when you give
something to someone and they feel
touched and warmed and loved by what
you've done it is I think the embodiment
of love
keep on now David my gosh one two three
girls all got me my computer
it's an awesome job McConnell you can
take pictures I live inside you really
do know what I want to have something to
give and to be able to experience the
joy of giving and to see the people who
receive there's nothing more magical
than that I was like the cutest sweetest
thing of all time I've never seen a kids
face light up like that I just have this
like bubbling joy feeling the guy have a
huge respect for all the people out
there who are Santa's we're all
collected and that that is really what
Christmas is about what Santa Claus is
about and what the magic about it's that
web between us all that connects us all
should we get your sister to come up
here just caring about someone else can
really be the difference between being
lonely and being loved I think because
you've been both been such good girls to
your mom's
you both should have a present so we
have a surprise for you as well
that's okay you'll understanding I think
it's great that you guys are such good
girls for your families you are studying
and you're gonna go a lot of great
places in your life and this is just to
help you along the way you even don't
really need this but this is something
that you deserve for me to be able to
give that to someone today just once was
a was really cool I think we did a
really good thing
Merry Christmas Santa Merry Christmas
Santa